lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
hablar sobre la gráfica de residuos para
cierta recta de regresión y los datos
que trata de explicar aquí tenemos una
recta de regresión por mínimos cuadrados
bastante sencilla para acomodar cuatro
puntos en vídeos anteriores encontramos
la ecuación de esta recta de regresión
por mínimos cuadrados lo que vamos a
hacer ahora es graficar los residuos de
cada uno de estos puntos que es un
residuo
recordemos que el residuo de un punto
dado es igual al valor real menos el
valor esperado
cuál es el residuo de este punto para
este punto el valor real de para x igual
a 1 es 1 pero el valor esperado cuando x
es igual a 1 es según esta recta de
regresión por mínimos cuadrados 2.5 por
uno menos 2 es 0.5 por lo que nuestro
residuo es 1 menos 0.5 nos da 0.5
positivo para este otro punto no tenemos
recibo ya que el valor real es el valor
esperado para este punto de acá el valor
real
cuando x es igual a 2 es igual a 2 pero
el valor esperado estrés por lo que
nuestro residuo aquí va a ser el valor
real es igual a 2 cuando x es igual a 2
y el valor esperado es 2.5 por 2 - 2 lo
que nos da 3 el residuo es 2 menos tres
que es igual a menos uno y para este
punto de aquí arriba el valor real
cuando x es igual a 36 y el valor
esperado cuando x es igual a 3 es 2.5
por 3 menos dos que nos da 5.5 por lo
que 6 menos 5.5 nos da punto 5 positivos
estos son los residuos de estos puntos
pero como los gráfica moss dibujamos
nuestros ejes ponemos 1 2 3
y el máximo de residuos aquí es 0.5 y el
mínimo es menos 1 así que en el eje
ponemos 0.5 y 1 y menos 0.5 y menos 1
cual es el residuo el valor real es 1 y
el valor esperado es 0.5 uno menos 0.5
es igual a 0.5 por lo que el residuo es
0.5 positivo lo escribimos justo aquí
cuando x es igual a 2 tenemos dos puntos
primero haremos este cuando tenemos el
punto 23 el residuo es igual a 0 lo
dibujamos para el punto 22 el residuo es
menos 1 lo indicamos con otro color para
el último punto cuando x es igual a 3 el
residuo es 0.5 positivo que dibujamos
acá esto que acabo de dibujar nos
muestra que para las x de los puntos
correspondientes dibujamos un punto por
arriba o por abajo del eje con base en
el residuo a esto le llamamos gráfica de
residuos una
porque las personas se toman la molestia
de dibujar una gráfica de residuos como
esta la respuesta es que sin importar
que la recta de regresión tenga una
pendiente positiva o negativa esto nos
da una idea de que también se ajusta la
recta a los datos y qué tan buena es la
recta para explicar la relación entre
las variables la idea general es que si
aquí vemos los puntos más o menos
repartidos igual arriba y abajo de esta
recta sin que se vea una tendencia en
particular aquí entonces la recta
probablemente es un buen modelo para los
datos pero si vemos algún tipo de
tendencia por ejemplo si los residuos
mostraran una tendencia hacia arriba o
si se curvan hacia abajo y luego hacia
arriba o si la tendencia fuera hacia
abajo podríamos decir que esta recta no
se ajusta bien por lo que probablemente
tengamos que usar un modelo no lineal
veamos algunos ejemplos de gráficas de
residuos para analizarlas aquí tenemos
una recta de regresión con su gráfica de
residuos correspondientes aquí
que este residuo es ligeramente positivo
lo que se nota en la gráfica de residuos
este otro punto tiene un residuo un poco
más positivo y lo vemos aquí pero como
en el ejemplo anterior parece que todos
estos residuos están uniformemente
espaciados por arriba y por debajo de la
línea además de que no se nota alguna
tendencia específica en la ubicación de
estos puntos podemos decir que este
modelo lineal en particular de esta
recta de regresión es un buen modelo
para estos datos pero si nos encontramos
una gráfica como ésta tenemos algo
diferente al ver solamente en la gráfica
de residuos no parece que los puntos
están uniformemente espaciados vemos una
tendencia en la gráfica primero bajamos
y luego subimos cuando vemos algo así de
extraño podemos decir que un modelo
lineal no es el más adecuado para
representar esto quizá necesitamos usar
un modelo no lineal para que represente
mejor estos datos
quizá la relación entre la ley y la x no
es lineal otra forma de pensar en esto
es que cuando tenemos muchos residuos
que están lejos del eje
en la gráfica de residuos también
podemos decir que esta línea no se
ajusta bien a los datos al calcular el
valor de r aquí será ligeramente
positivo pero no será cercano a 1 y con
esto terminamos